bonjour mesdames messieurs je voudrais
avoir un renseignement concernant les
ateliers à 21 ans jérémy entame sa
deuxième année de bts dans le commerce
et il est venu spécialement aujourd'hui
attrape au lycée de la plaine de 9 pour
préparer sa recherche d'emploi
j'achète informations concernant le cv
la lettre de motivation savoir comme on
le réalise
car chez des informations sur certains
secteurs d'activité sur certaines
filières ateliers conférences et
conseils l'événement attrape ton avenir
a réuni élèves dès la 3eme étudiants une
cinquantaine de professionnels leur
présentait des filières d'art par
exemple peu ou pas connus nous avons
également des services publics
représentés donc nous avons une grande
diversité de métiers et filières qui
sont présentés d'une part et d'autre
part nous avons des stands tenus par nos
propres élèves qui présentent leurs
réalisations
une journée portes ouvertes qui a
accueilli près de 1000 personnes
à l'issue de ces entretiens jérémy fait
le bilan bien formulé dans l'ensemble
nombreux professionnels rencontrés que
du bonus pour moi pour la suite de mes
études et ma soeur mon avenir
professionnel première édition de cet
événement dédié à l'orientation un
rendez vous qui devrait revenir chaque
année